E aí
Oi boa tarde a todos
eu sou Nilson carreto e tivemos a ideia
diferente dentro da situação que
aconteceu com meu filho e numa luta de
boxe ele vez sofreu um golpe e
ficou em coma no hospital durante 16
dias
que desse intermédio aí eu fui para o
hospital não soube mais do que era comer
beber dormir e nem muito menos tomar
banho fiquei lá enquanto aí no céu de lá
não sair junto com ele os pés dias
consecutivos médico falava que ele ia
morrer
quatro dia depois de operar de ficar
paraplégico
e um garoto com 21 anos de repente ia
postar a situação na vida dele que mudar
toda a nossa forma de ver o mundo
acontecer
aquele garoto jovem e de repente Deus te
ver a piedade de compaixão conosco e me
deu a vida do meu filho novamente dentro
do que ele me deu a vida eu larguei
família lá de tudo e vir para Rua cuidar
dos filhos dele e dentro de uma situação
que eu comecei com as crianças que
cheirava a cola Etienne quando eu pensei
que não dá no Vale do Anhangabaú sou eu
o prefeito de São Paulo na época
José Ferrari me considero um espaço no
bexiga e uma pequena academia de sucata
que não tinha nem saco de boxe pesa pau
geladeira pneu amortecedor de carro mola
de caminhão passou a ter um projeto
social
a
Deus pois a mão naquilo e passei a ser o
uma situação diferente comecei a
reciclar seres humanos
uma coisa totalmente renovável dentro do
nosso planeta porque quando nós nós se
Deus da vida e quando ainda não valoriza
a vida a gente perde a essência da vida
como um monte que entregam lá droga na
prostituição no molde de atendimento
dentro de um lar e faz com que eles vão
para rua e deixa de se valorizar como
seres humanos que a própria sociedade
passa fazer com que eles realmente
ficam discriminado ao ponto de que a
própria a própria situação faz com que
eles passam assaltar roubar e foi a
própria sociedade venda o nosso trabalho
começando os conselheiros doações aonde
a gente começou ajudar eles a se
acreditar que ele pudesse montar uma
vida e graças a isso pode maior poder
que nós temos dentro do nosso trabalho é
fazer com que ele se entregue à
associação a sociedade através daquilo
que a sociedade não dá que a
credibilidade e um livro um caderno uma
roupa usada que nós damos para eles e o
esporte em si que hoje dentro do que nós
fizemos com o tanto tanta garra tanta
competência
passou-se 14 anos e de repente uma
empresa chegou lá me deu 800 mil reais e
materiais de musculação num ringue de
MMA o único debaixo do viaduto no
planeta e um novo género de Muay Thai
que eu já tenho de boxe e dentro de sair
nós estamos tentando fazer agora uma
nova essência do do esporte para
resgatar mais os jovens dessas situações
da África que o país está enfrentando
como no mundo inteiro e trazendo aí
novos campeões através do Esporte e esse
é o Projeto Garrido quem recicla seres
humanos de baixo no viaduto a
e
eu fico até um pouco Emocionado Porque
essa é a primeira vez que eu tô vendo
esse vídeo que eu não tenho tempo nem às
vezes e dormir que dele assistir os
vídeos né e quando esse
repórter teve lá nós tivemos uma
primeira vez
560 pessoas passando no projeto um mês
atrasado tivemos
5.860 assinatura no caderno pelas
pessoas que por lá passaram Fazendo
atividade física gratuitamente e o mês
que acabou agora passou
então lá no espaço cada segundo que uma
pessoa tá lá dentro seja ela qual for a
natureza dela a sociedade Tá mais
protegido aqui fora porque a cada
segundo hoje cada minuto a gente vê uma
família ser destruída pela forma que ele
tiver a mídia a tarde falando das coisas
que acontecem dentro do Brasil não é
mais em São Paulo que hoje vira uma
cadeia Nacional então acredito sim que
dentro que nós tentamos fazer com o
sacrifício sem um órgão governamental
sem Empresarial temos a força maior além
da primeiramente a força divina e além
da força da própria sociedade que lá
acredita Ah entendi doando muitas coisas
para nós ir nós ajuda todas as pessoas
como também não me nosso projeto nós não
fazemos bazar beneficiente e não fazemos
também brechó tudo que vai dar que vamos
nós guardamos se tem um problema numa
favela que pegou fogo nós corremos para
lá de imediatamente querendo saber o que
está acontecendo para poder ver o que
que nós possamos dá para aquelas pessoas
necessitadas né com a mesma coisa mais
gente nós não temos esse vínculo dizer
não tem que estar lá para o governo das
coisas porque o povo deu para nós na
confiança que a hora que alguém precisar
nós somos pronto para dar então o
projeto totalmente inovador uma nova
forma de fazer os acontecimentos aqui
acreditando sim que a própria sociedade
junto com alguém diferenciado que para
chegar lá e peça credibilidade foi preso
Algemado deu porrada
pesado com vagabundo que queria o espaço
e a própria situação da Ltda Ah entendi
então acredito que dentro de que veio
tudo contra 11 foi contra todos e
mostrou que realmente todo junto poderia
fazer uma diferença com a minoria até
aquela parte negativa que acreditava que
poderia tirar proveito dali usando as
pessoas de forma errada então agradeço
sem a sociedade por ter me dado esse ego
de fazer algo diferente dentro de tudo e
foi graças a Deus que eu agradeço muito
a Ele tem dado aquela porrada na cabeça
do meu filho e meu filho ter parado de
parou para que me desse uma visão
diferente me dado força e acima de tudo
determinação para que nós juntos pudesse
me fazer algo diferente então hoje nós
temos aí no Brasil uma porta totalmente
novavel reciclando os seres humanos
muito obrigado a